I was going through a period in my own
career where I was struggling to trust
people everybody keeps telling us trust
is important but they don't tell us what
trust is or how it's built
simultaneously I just happen to be
spending time with folks in the military
and I kept meeting these people who
would willingly risk their lives to save
the lives of people they didn't even
like whereas in business you know we
don't even want to give up credit for
things let alone Our Lives I started
asking the question how do I get people
like that at work my original theory was
that they're just better people and
better people are drawn to this life of
service and the more I started to learn
the more I started to investigate the
more I realized I was completely wrong
it's not actually about the person it's
about the environment you can take a
good person and put them in a bad
environment and they will do bad things
conversely you can take someone who may
have been perceived as untrustworthy you
can change their environment and they
can change their lives and become
valuable members of a team leaders set
the environment so if you can create an
environment biologically trust will
follow